Le clash des plateformes
Tu sais Damien, franchement
je suis hyper contente
qu'on s'installe ensemble
Ouais.
et qu'on ait notre petit nid à nous mais…
Quand même !
Elle est pas un peu énorme cette télé ?
Non, franchement
c'est la bonne taille
pour mater des trucs ou je ne sais pas,
jouer à la console
bref, je range où mes affaires ?
Ah, je ne sais pas
j'ai la flemme.
- On se pose ?
- OK.
Je vais prendre une douche
et toi tu choisis un truc à regarder ?
Un truc qui justifie
que tu défigures mon salon.
Yes.
Ça va être à moi.
J'ai une super série.
C'est des coréens qui sont enfermés
et pour sortir, ils doivent
- Squid Game ?
- Déjà vu.
OK, pas de souci, pas de souci.
J'ai une série documentaire énorme.
- C'est sur
- Un tueur en série ?
Tu n'as que ça de toute façon.
Pas du tout.
Non, n'importe quoi.
Euh, c'est sur…
Une secte.
C'est sur un tueur en série dans une secte.
Mais c'est pas grave.
J'ai des films également.
Là, je devine qu'il cherche Star Wars.
Il n'a pas du tout demandé Star Trek
t'es au courant de ça quand même ?
C'est quasiment ce qu'il a demandé !
Je lui propose à 92 %.
En même temps tu recommandes
tout à 92 %, c'est facile aussi.
Oui, bien, vas-y, gros malin,
propose-lui un film.
Je suis sûr que tu ne
l'as même pas Star Wars.
Franchement, la vérité :
peut-être, peut-être pas.
- Je sais pas.
- Oui bon, de toute façon
impossible de trouver quoi
que ce soit avec ton interface.
C'est tellement le bordel.
Mais moi, c'est pas
mon métier à la base !
Je fais ça en hobby, OK ?
Bon, 9 euros, ça ne va pas me tuer.
Les garçons, ne vous battez pas.
C'est moi qui ai racheté Star Wars, voilà.
J'ai aussi racheté Les Simpson,
X-Men, Pixar…
Mais, moi aussi je veux
des trucs chers à acheter.
J'ai aussi racheté Marvel,
et surtout, j'ai tous les classiques
avec lesquels il a grandi.
Parce qu'un petit Star Wars, sinon ?
Ah non, j'ai l'impression qu'on
les a tous vus une fois.
Ouais c'est bien ce qu'il me semblait.
Mais c'était sûr, Disney Plus
t'as que des trucs qu'on
a vus, revus, re-revus.
Alors, j'ai aussi plein de nouveautés.
J'ai une série sur le chien de "Là-Haut"
sur le demi-frère de Thor
sur la fourchette de Toy Story
Sur la fourchette de Toy Story…
Mais tu t'écoutes un peu, Disney Plus ?
Ça va être quoi la prochaine fois ?
Le frère jumeau de Ratatouille ?
La verrue plantaire de Vaiana ?
De Vaiana...
Le crypto et voilà.
Je viens de racheter les droits
pour Roland-Garros et La Ligue 1.
Bien sûr, oui.
Damien vient d'emménager chez sa meuf, là
ils vont passer leur premier moment intime
ils vont se mater un petit Brest-FC Nantes.
- T'as raison.
- C'est vrai...
Il faut pas que Damien oublie
les plateformes françaises
parce qu'on a quand même Game of Thrones
Walking Dead, Succession.
Toutes les séries HBO, quoi.
Ouais, oui, c'est vrai.
Vous êtes au courant que HBO
ils vont arriver en France ?
Ah non, j'étais pas au courant.
Ils vont récupérer tout leur catalogue.
Oh putain, je suis dans la merde !
Je suis dans la merde !
Qu'est-ce qui nous reste ?
Oh putain, je n'ai rien, putain !
Moi, j'ai "Meurtres à Rocamadour".
Vous n'avez pas entendu
un bruit de merde là ?
Ouais, c'est Salto,
il est tout au bout.
Ah oui, c'est la plateforme
de France Télé, M6, TF1.
Attendez, vous allez vous marrer.
Salto ! Dis-moi, tu as quoi
en stock genre ?
Je proposerais peut-être Capitaine Marleau.
Je vous l'avais dit.
Il me tue le con.
Je le garde là, pas loin.
Ah putain, les Français,
vous me faites marrer, putain.
Bonjour !
My Canal, enchanté.
Attendez, depuis quand
Damien il a MyCanal ?
Depuis que son père
lui prête son compte.
Ça sert à ça, la famille.
C'est de la triche ça.
D'ailleurs, j'ai une offre qui vous
comprend tous, sauf Prime.
Prime, tu ne veux pas me rejoindre ?
Je m'en branle.
Merde.
Je crois que Damien a
oublié le mot de passe
et son père doit dormir, fait chier.
Ah ben, regardez
Damien, il me choisit en plus.
Voilà, un petit film d'action à l'ancienne.
Putain, mais il n'y a pas de sous-titres.
Je vous l'avais dit, je vérifie rien moi.
Je mets les films, il se démerde.
Sous-titres, pas sous-titres, voilà
Il apprendra l'anglais, c'est très bien.
Excusez-moi, je crois que Damien
rajoute une nouvelle plateforme.
7 jours gratuits...
Bonjour , Apple TV Plus.
Bonjour, moi c'est Salto.
On n'a pas besoin
d'une plateforme en plus !
Il fait pas des téléphones
et des ordinateurs, lui à la base.
Vous n'êtes plus vraiment à la page
J'ai des séries telles que The Morning Show,
Ted Lasso,
ou une série avec Jason Momoa.
Ouais, et ?
Et c'est tout.
C'est tout.
J'ai quand même Jennifer Aniston, Steve Carell
Chris Evans, Justin Timberlake
des dizaines de récompenses
pour chaque série.
Je pense que Damien et sa compagne
préfèrent la qualité à la quantité.
N'est-ce pas, Prime ?
J'ai Jurassic Park 2.
Mais je ne trouve plus le un.
C'est moi qui l'ai.
Enfin, c'est "Les dents de la mer".
Mais c'est le même réalisateur.
Et puis, c'est une bestiole qui bouffe des gens.
Donc, c'est à peu près pareil.
Je le recommande à 92 %.
Je ne veux pas attirer l'attention,
mais moi, j'ai "Recherche appartement ou maison".
En avant-première.
Après, il faut aimer Stéphane Plaza.
Un petit film d'horreur sinon.
Voilà, c'est bien ça !
Il me choisit.
Je ne savais même pas qu'on avait ce film.
Mais c'est payant, putain !
Ouais, je l'ai, mais payant.
Ouais, donc, tu l'as pas, quoi.
Donc je ne l'ai pas.
Pssst, Damien !
Damien, viens ici.
J'ai tout gratuit. C'est zéro euro, viens !
Torrent, on te voit là.
Non, mais continuez.
Faites comme si je n'existais pas là.
Et continuez à augmenter les prix aussi
c'est bien pour mon business.
On n'augmente pas les prix.
Il parle de Netflix, je crois.
Quoi ? Moi, je n'augmente pas les prix.
Enfin, sauf une fois au ch-
Trois fois. J'ai compté.
Mais Salto, t'es un fayot, c'est fou !
Oui, j'augmente un peu
les prix de temps en temps,
mais je suis là depuis 2014
on verra dans quelques années vos prix.
Netflix, je suis là depuis plus longtemps que toi
je suis toujours gratos.
D'accord, désormais, il y a YouTube.
Nous parlons de vrais contenus,
des séries ou des films
pas des challenges ou
des courts métrages de Cyprien.
Pardon ?
Les Vlogs d'août de Léna Situations.
Cinq saisons, 31 épisodes
ou les Vacances des Croûtons,
des millions de spectateurs.
« Gratuit », mon cul, YouTube
on a vu le nombre de pubs
que tu mets avant tes vidéos.
Une petite au début.
Trois, j'ai compté.
C'est pas de ma faute si Damien
c'est un gros rat, là
il ne veut pas payer YouTube Premium.
Damien, Damien, laisse-les s'embrouiller.
J'ai tout gratuit. Viens, Damien.
Même des séries en V.O.,
avec les sous-titres et tout ?
Bien sûr, je te trouve ça d'un
claquement de doigt.
Bon, OK, faut remplacer les points d'interrogation
par les apostrophes et le carré
c'est un C cédille.
Et les sous-titres sont décalés.
N'importe quoi !
Enfin, à part ça…
C'est du vol.
Du vol, s'il te plaît, MyCanal
tu as vu le prix que tu coûtes ?
Attendez, Apple TV Plus il coûte cher aussi.
Netflix a augmenté de prix
pendant qu'on parle.
Oh l'bâtard !
Un euro ! Ça va ! Personne n'avait remarqué
avant que vous en parliez là, putain !
Je rappelle que j'ai tout le catalogue de la Fox
- ainsi que Star...
- Damien, viens !
Puis Marvel, Avengers.
J'ai quand même plus de 4000 films et séries.
Moi aussi !
Et je lui rajoute un Sub Twitch
pour le streamer de son choix.
- Les Marseillais contre le reste du monde ?
- Apple TV Plus est LA solution.
Un tuto ! Comment réparer
une machine à laver.
- Il me reste un peu de sport.
-  Un challenge peut-être…
Tu t'en sors ?
Ouais.
C'est moi ou tu t'es abonné
à 17 plateformes de streaming ?
Non, mais le premier mois était gratuit.
Et tu as choisi quoi, du coup ?
Je m'étais dit que peut-être
sur Net… sur Prime, sur…
Enfin peut-être un vlog, il y a… sur Salto…
Ça a l'air pas mal ça, non ?
Quoi ?
Je ne sais pas, l'acteur principal
c'est pas Pierre Niney mais
il est pas mal, et l'actrice
elle a quelque chose, non ?
Ça parle de quoi ?
C'est une histoire d'amour.
Ce n'est pas trop gnan-gnan, j'espère.
Un peu, mais ça marche bien.
J'ai vu que le début, c'est vraiment super.
Je ne sais pas ce que ça donne après.
Ce n'est pas un très gros budget par contre.
Ouais, non, mais j'avais vu
parce que les décors
ne sont pas dinguissimes.
C'est une histoire qui me plaît bien.
Moi aussi, ça me plaît beaucoup.
Ça, j'achète direct !
Non, non, moi, j'achète.
Ça va faire une super série !
Il me le faut ! Avant que HBO arrive.
Je transforme lui en super mutant
elle en super héroïne, ça va faire un carton
Non, laissez-le-moi.
Je n'ai rien, moi, depuis le début.